and so when you go to start like it
makes sense right a lot of not necessary
professional athletes but a lot of like
content creators and stuff now a real
singer wait a second if the advertising
is valuable to the advertiser like it's
very valuable to me to write like I
should probably build this stuff how are
you going about you know this is a
couple years ago so it's not like you
know the internet and kind of all the
tools we have today but when you go to
start that backpack company or that
skateboard company or whatever like or
you literally doing it by yourself
are you building teams are you trying to
use other tools like I just walk through
kind of like operationally how you were
trying to do it
it's a good a good question so I I
learned through experience the
importance of building a team and that
was because I was still skateboarding
right like that like I said I have a
point where I was still skateboarding
him strength start businesses and each
one demands so much time so the only way
you're able to do two things at once is
if you have people come together and
help you achieve both together and so
the first company I started and it's not
even the first the first shoe I had to
find people to help me operate them from
a day-to-day standpoint because I wasn't
able to dedicate that much time so how I
would do at the beginning was I would
spend a lot of time creating the company
helping create the team and launching it
and then once the point of launching it
then I was able to free up some time to
then put towards skateboarding and then
participate heavily on the marketing
side and then any of like the bigger
picture decisions and conversation and
then that led to which is awesome when I
started my next company when it was a
hundred percent business and no longer
skateboarding
I was already trained that I need people
to help me create this vision I am it's
not possible for me to do it alone
and so that was a huge learning lesson
that I was fortunate to learn through
this hybrid model of me still skating
and did you were you one of the first
skaters to kind of say hey wait a second
rather than advertise somebody else's
stuff I'll just create my own or did you
learn that from somebody learned it so
there was a skateboarder called Jamie
Thomas
and he was he was so implement
influential to me because one I saw him
in a video one time like he was filming
one of the skaters and he was like one
of the gnarliest best pro skateboarders
of all time and I saw him in a video
filming another skater I was like whoa
this guy's films also and then I found
out that he owned the company he rode
for which was zero and then he ended up
starting a shoe company called fallen
and he was the first example where I
went oh my gosh
theatres can be more than speeders they
could own the things they're doing and
so he was I think the first example that
I saw and then there were a handful of
others but truthfully not that many yeah
it's so fascinating and then in terms of
walking away from skating you pretty
much had spent it sounds like almost 20
years of your life doing this maybe even
more why stop what was kind of the
impetus for saying alright maybe maybe I
shouldn't do this anymore
so okay remember I told you no one
skateboarding became a job for me
I had to find a new love in it so there
was a point where like whatever I love
skateboarding and then all of a sudden
you know the pressure the requirements
there was a time where I didn't like it
anymore and I ended up falling in love
with the business side of my ski career
and that happened around the same time
to me getting a shoe and I started
experiencing you know everything that
goes into selling product sales
marketing you know it designed it was I
was fascinated by it and once I got a
first shoe then I started looking at
okay I can do tricks but how can I reach
more people what platforms can I get on
to grow my audience and and how can i
connect with them that is then in turn
gonna help me sell more product and I
started loving that process and then
even when I started my first company
it just started reinforcing this new
passion that I enjoy building something
and so with with my skateboarding and
why it ended up ending
I had my sponsors a to sponsors that
were my main income ended up letting me
go and it was at a point where I have
just had surgery and so I was laying on
the couch
got a call all of my income in a way and
I was probably I don't know twelve
months maybe eleven months away from
being a hundred percent being recovered
100% and so I kind of had to make a
decision it was like okay I'm 34 years
old
I have passion for for the business side
I can't skateboard for another year I
have no income coming in what are my
options and I looked at it as my options
were I can he'll try to get more
sponsors and maybe I'm two years out
possibly from making money again as a
pro skateboarder or I use this time as
as the time to truly step away and I
looked at it as there was even if I
tried to get sponsored again
I was only trying to delay being
inevitable because there's only a so
there's only long I only have so much
time for sponsors to pay me and so I
ended up stepping away and it was brutal
it wasn't easy it was it was it was such
a hard decision because I expected my
career to end a certain way and it ended
such a different way and I think all of
us naturally wanna we want things to
happen on our terms
and it didn't and there was a point
where I had to wrestle with that and
then ultimately accept it but that's
ultimately why because it no longer
became a career and then I lost the new
purpose I had in skateboarding because
now the business element wasn't there
either yeah
and before we get into what you did
after your skate career do you still
skate and how often I still skate not
like I use I mean I when I say I was
obsessed even as a pro I would skate
five hours a day every single day for
probably twenty something years like
thousands and thousands and thousands of
hours now I don't know once a week maybe
once every two weeks a lot I mean for
the average person that's definitely a
lot right for the average I would say
for the average 36 year old who has
three kids and a business days doing
full-time that's a pretty good amount I
love it